you have to let other people's dream of
you die so that your dream can live
because there's only so much of you to
go around everybody else is trying to
get you to be the version of you that
best serves them including your family I
don't think it's a malicious intention
but they have goals for you that are
probably not your goals for you and
somebody's goals have to die and where
most of them die is right in the middle
which is you try and do theirs and you
try and do yours and you actually
accomplish neither so you might as well
do 100% yours do none of theirs and then
actually achieve the longterm goal which
they probably have is that you live a
happy and successful life